even though a lot of people are still
dealing with the impact of the pandemic
i know this is going to sound crazy it's
a great time to start a small business
told you going to sound crazy right
craig kirkland with nevada state bank is
joining us live to talk more about that
good morning craig thank you so much for
being here how you doing
good morning monica you're doing well
it's good to be with you all right so
let me tell you something when i when i
um decided to do this topic and i heard
that
uh this is a great time to start a
business i was like okay this guy must
be nuts because nobody else sees this
as a great time to start a business but
tell us about
you know your credit you mean joe public
uh being cheaper and programs available
for like micro loans uh for small
businesses
and their intermediaries talk about that
for me sure monica
the small business administration the
sba has some
really attractive financing right now
well first of all
you can get an sba loan for working
capital to acquire or expand the
business
and they'll make your payments for the
first three months until the end of
september
or until the funds run out and also
they're waiving their traditional fee
which can be as high as 2.7 percent
2.75 of the loan amount
uh and the third thing is they're
guaranteeing to lenders
up to 90 percent of the loan which means
limit could take a little more risk
yeah and okay so we talk about like the
recession
and how it's hurt people but you guys
say that it's giving leverage to those
considering starting a small business
what is the leverage because i'm sure
you can understand craig people right
now
are hurting really bad and they're
getting back online but what i'm hearing
from the community is that it's taken a
heck of a lot of work
yeah well some of the advantages right
now is if you're looking for
a space to lease a space you can really
negotiate for more favorable terms you
may
get a break on your rent for a period of
time you may get
money to do the the tenant improvements
the build out of the space
you may be able to get better terms from
suppliers
cheaper equipment as well
and so there's opportunity when there's
during a recession
now your team says that uncertainty can
be a powerful
motivator again i'm not smart like this
i'm on the outside looking in so
the only thing uh that uncertainty
causes me
is stress explain that what are some of
the advantages and the disadvantages
well uncertainty is the powerful
motivator right for people
yeah and there's a lot of resources out
there so if you have an idea if you have
a desire
tap into some of the resources available
such as through the small
business development corporation and
crippling that will help you start a
business plan and build out and
visualize what you want to accomplish
yeah talk to our viewers craig about
some of your other programs if they're
thinking about doing it because
you know when you follow social media
you hear about people inventing things
during the pandemic
you hear about moms and pops getting in
the kitchen and making soaps and candles
and all this kind of stuff
talk about some of those other
advantages yeah
well i i think the important thing is to
is to network
is to connect with your local chambers
to hear about things and resources that
are made
available to you and to be out there
networking and talking
and learning invest in yourself by
learning there's a lot of information
available online
and through non-profit resources all
right so if somebody is watching this
they're like you know what craig i don't
know what you're talking about but i
really want to talk to you
in person to try and get something going
how do they get in touch with you and
you know what kind of appointment should
they make with the bank
sure they can go online and they can
schedule an appointment
with us in one of our branches they can
also go to nevadasmallbusiness.com
and we have a a series of resources
available there
and follow my blog i have craig's common
sense and where i share
basic information for for consumers and
businesses but a lot of resources out
there educate yourself
network uh always be looking to to
mentor
uh find people to help mentor you and
accomplish what you're looking for
and you know what one of the things you
mentioned uh craig that my husband and i
found out is that the
chambers if you can get involved with
the your local chamber of commerce you
talk about major resources oh my
goodness
i was blown away by that so that is a
really great point
yeah yeah uh you know they talk about
always be
closing i say always be network always
be
always educate yourself very cool very
cool all right
that this is craig kirkland he is the
executive vice president and retail
banking director over at nevada state
bank thank you so much for your advice
and your time we appreciate you
thank you monica all right take care and
folks don't forget to catch my
moj show facebook live tonight hey if
you're a local restaurant owner small
business speaking of you do want to tune
in the mlj show is doing something
really cool for you all right here in
the las vegas community y'all know i
love getting out there and helping
where and when i can